et clara juste avant ça ce que certains
chroniqueurs ont essayé de refaire en
photo sur un ca parce que bon on te suit
aucune personne qu'on suit beaucoup sur
un sarthois wade moi je suis je suis
très bien je n'ai pas fait alors je n'ai
pas fait c'est je vais le dire avec
toutes les photos que j'ai fait ça je
suis choquée d'être débordé de quoi on
va voir alors ça c'est kara bien entendu
on regarder avec un magnifique bouquet
de roses et derrière on a regardé comme
c'est beau à sannois pas du rêve au
cauchemar
et bravo bungie qui jouent le jeu montre
et oui voilà voilà ça c'est tout simple
voilà et après qui on a qui a fait cela
au web alors qu'il fallait je peux je
peux préciser quelque chose par rapport
à la production cyril qu'on aime tant on
m'a dit viens t'inquiète pas on a toutes
les affaires possibles donc faut
préciser que c'est le maillot que
portait benjamin castaldi juste avant
non on m'a dit on va te mettre des
pinces à linge juste derrière parce
qu'on n'a pas ta taille les convives
non mais toutes étaient nettoyés bien
évidemment donc je remercie la
production qui a fait un très très beau
travail
vous avez une double clôture on a
d'autres choses c'est parti regardez oui
ça c'est vera qui se maquille on l'a
regardé pas mal comme à regarder même le
public ces barrières gardées
une dernière une dernière ou pas on en a
merci ah oui ça là oui ça c'est claque
qu'ils pensaient si elle devait faire
pousser des ailes moreau c'est pas ma
mère dernière
mes fils est extraordinaire ah oui
intriguant et presque huit mois et ça va
s'arrêter quand ces photos on a quoi
d'autre heureusement que ce n'est pas
leur langue est vassala les belles oktar
et vous avez d'un refait le tatouage
tribal fusion céder sur rien au hasard
dans cette émission